AND THANKS FOR COMING TO THE
ELECTIONS AND REDISTRICTING
COMMITTEE HEARING FOR MAY NINTH
TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
THERE FIVE BILLS UP IN OUR
COMMITTEE TODAY.
THREE BILLS.
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY NINE ITEM NUMBER TWO. AB
TWENTY SIX SIXTY FIVE AND I ITEM
NUMBER THREE.
A. B..
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY FIVE.
.
ARE ON CONSENT AS WELL AS ITEM
NUMBER FIVE A. B. THIRTY TO
FIFTY NINE BY THE ELECTIONS ARE
DISTURBING COMMITTEE. AS
PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED AS
SUGGESTED IN COMMON NUMBER SEVEN
OF THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
I DOES ANY MEMBER WHICH TERM.
BUT WE DON'T A QUORUM SO WE'RE
NOT GOING TO HAVE IT ON THE HEAD.
.
BUT WE DO HAVE AN AUTHOR SO WHEN
WE GET STARTED. DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
IF YOU'D LIKE TO PRESENT ITEM
NUMBER FOUR I BELIEVE.
AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY NINE
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY NINE
SIMPLY STATES THAT THE VOTING
DOMICILE FOR A PERSON WHO IS
CLASSIFIED AS A SEXUALLY VIOLENT
PREDATOR. AND WHO IS COMMITTED
FOR AN INDETERMINATE TERM IN A
STATE HOSPITAL.
SHALL BE THE PERSON'S LAST KNOWN
ADDRESS OF RESIDENTS.
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT AN
SBP VOTES IN THE COUNTY AND OR
CITY WHERE HE OR SHE LAST LIVED.
BEFORE THEY WERE CONVICTED OF
THEIR SEX OFFENSE.
INSTEAD OF THE CITY AND COUNTY
WHERE THE STATE HOSPITAL IS
LOCATED.
COURT RULINGS HAVE GRANTED SDP'S
THE RIGHT TO VOTE THIS MEASURE
CLARIFIES WHERE AN SP PEAS
VOTING DOMICILE IS.
EXISTING LAW PROVIDES THAT A
PERSON DOES NOT GAIN OR LOSE A
DOMICILE SOLELY BY REASON OF HIS
OR HER PRESENCE OR ABSENCE.
FROM A PLACE WHILE BEING KEPT IN
AN ASYLUM ARE PRESENT.
THIS BILL JUST CLARIFIES THAT
THE VOTING DOMICILE PRESS HE
PEES.
THERE ARE APPROXIMATELY NINE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SEXUALLY
VIOLENT PREDATORS IN CALIFORNIA
THAT HAVE BEEN COMMITTED FOR
INDETERMINATE TERMS.
ALL OF THEM ARE HOUSED A COOLING
THE STATE HOSPITAL IN FRESNO
COUNTY.
MOST OF THEM.
IF NOT ALL OF THEM HAVE NO
HISTORY OF LIVING IN FRESNO
COUNTY OR IN THE CITY OF CALLING.
LAST YEAR THE CALLING THE CITY
COUNCIL PLACE THE MEASURE ON THE
BALLOT. THAT WOULD HAVE
INCREASED THE SALES TAX BY ONE
PERCENT.
THE SALES TAX THAT NEEDED TO
ADDRESS THE BUDGET DEFICIT
THAT WOULD HAVE ALLOWED THE CITY
TO RETAIN TWENTY THREE CITY
POSITIONS.
MAINTAINING POLICE OFFICER AND
FIREFIGHTER STAFFING LEVELS.
THE MEASURE WENT BEFORE THE
VOTERS IN NOVEMBER OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN.
AND THE SALES TAX MEASURE FAILED
BY THIRTY SEVEN VOTES.
FIVE HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO TO FIVE
HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE.
ACCORDING TO THE CITY MOST OF
THE STATE HOSPITALS THREE
HUNDRED FOUR REGISTERED VOTERS.
VOTED AGAINST THE TAX.
AS A RESULT THE CITY WAS FORCED
TO CUT TWENTY THREE POSITIONS.
AND TO REDUCE THE POLICE FORCE
BY TWENTY FIVE PERCENT.
THE SP PIECE THAT VOTED AGAINST
THE BALLOT MEASURE HAVE
ABSOLUTELY NO TIES TO CALLING.
AND NO WONDER STANDING OF WHAT
THE COMMUNITY NEEDS.
INSTEAD THEY MADE UNREASONABLE
DEMANDS FOR A SHUTTLE SERVICE TO
THE INSTITUTION.
ACCESS TO TAXI SERVICES AND LAND
FOR A VISITOR CENTER.
ALL THINGS THAT THEY CAN'T
UTILIZE.
IT IS UNFORTUNATE THAT THE
SEXUALLY VIOLENT PREDATORS AT.
STATE HOSPITAL WHERE ABLE TO
AFFECT THE OUTCOME OF AN ISSUE
SO IMPORTANT TO THE COMMUNITY.
PUBLIC SAFETY.
THEIR VOTES IMPACTED THE JOBS OF
TWENTY THREE POLICE OFFICERS AND
FIREFIGHTERS IN A CITY THAT
DESPERATELY NEEDS THEM.
THE SP PEAS ARE BEING HOUSED A
CALLING THE STATE HOSPITAL BY
COURT ORDER.
AND MOST IF NOT ALL OF THEM HAVE
NEVER LIVED IN PROBABLY NEVER
EVEN VISITED CALLING UP BEFORE
BEING SENT TO THE STATE
INSTITUTION.
THIS MEASURE SIMPLY INSURERS
THAT THE S. B. PEAS HOUSED AT
CAHUENGA ARE VOTING IN
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY HAVE SOME
TIES TO.
AND NOT THE COMMUNITY THAT THEY
WERE SENT TO BY COURT ORDER.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
I HAVE WITH ME THREE WITNESSES
MAYOR NATHAN VOSBURG FROM THE
CITY OF KALINDA.
AND.
SORRY BUT WE ALSO HAVE SUSAN FOX
FROM A CAPS
WHO'S NOT HERE YET.
GREAT AND IF. WE CAN JUST TAKE A
BRIEF PAUSE AS WE HAVE A QUORUM
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND TAKE.
ROLE TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM IN
THE COMMITTEE AUTUMN SECRETARY
PLEASE CULTURAL BERMAN HERE
BERMAN HERE HARPER PRESENT
HARPER HERE CALDERON.
CALDERON HERE LOW HERE LOW HERE
MULLIN.
STEINORTH STEINORTH HERE WEBER.
WE HAVE A QUORUM. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM SECRETARY.
PLEASE CONTINUE THEIR VOTES FOR.
MY NAME'S NATHAN VOSBURGH
MARRIAGE CITY KALANGA. NAM I
COME FROM A SMALL
DISENFRANCHISED COMMUNITY.
.
FOR POPULATION FROM TWO THOUSAND.
TEN CENSUS WAS THAT THIRTEEN
THREE EIGHT.
WE HAVE.
STATE HOSPITAL WE HAD HAD A A
PRISON KARMA BECAUSE THE CENTER.
THAT CUTS THROUGH CENTER WAS
GIVING US A MILLION DOLLARS OF
REVENUE TO GO TO A PUBLIC A
SAFETY.
DUE TO.
AB ONE ON NINE.
PROP 47-57 WE HAVE.
LOST THAT AND SO WE'VE LOST
ALSO THE REVENUE THAT CAME IN
WITH IT. WHICH ACTUALLY PUT OUR
CITY ABOUT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
IN DEBT.
.
AS YOU KNOW ABOUT TWELVE TO
FIFTEEN YEARS AGO. WE'D A OUR
COUNCIL DID VOTE IN FAVOR OF
MAKING DO WITH THE HOSPITAL TO
BRING THEM FOR JOBS AND
OPPORTUNITY. AT THAT POINT IN
TIME A IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT THE THE SEXUAL ESCAPEES
WERE NOT ABLE TO VOTE. IN OUR
LOCAL ELECTIONS AT THAT TIME COM.
I WAS ACTUALLY AGAINST BRINGING
IN THE STATE HOSPITAL. ALONG
WITH A LOT OF OUR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS WERE AGAINST IT WE
FIGURED IT WOULD BRING ABOUT
ELEMENT.
BUT JOBS AND OPPORTUNITIES INTO
IMPOVERISHED AREA.
THAT'S DISADVANTAGED
HIGHLY DISADVANTAGED IN SOME
AREAS ON.
OVERRODE THAT AND YOU KNOW WE
MOVE FOR WHAT THE AND IS ONE OF
THE TOP A JOB PROVIDERS THERE
HOWEVER EVERYONE SAYS NOT MY
BACKYARD. KALANGA ALLOWED THAT'S
IN OUR BACKYARD. AND WE ARE WE
HAVE WE HAVE DONE EVERYTHING
THAT THE STATE HAS ASKED US WE
HAD THE CUTS THE CUTS THE CENTER
FOR THE STATE WE HAD THE THE
STATE HOSPITAL FOR THE STATE.
AND UNFORTUNATELY A LOT OF THESE
THINGS THAT WE'RE DOING HAVE
ACTUALLY COME BACK TO BITE US.
THE STATE HOSPITAL SEVER THE
TIES WITH OUR HOSPITAL.
SO THEY NO LONGER TAKE INMATES
OR ANYBODY OVER TO THAT AREA
PATIENTS AND SO WE NOW HAVE LOST
OUR HOSPITAL AS WELL.
SO.
WEREN'T WERE WE WERE INFORMING
AND DEBT WERE CLIMBING OUR WAY
OUT.
.
ARE POLICE AND FIRE ONE BECAUSE
OF.
ERA PROP 47-57 AB ONE OF NINE
HAVE BEEN COMPLETELY OVERWHELMED
WE HAVE RE OFFENDERS.
IT'S IT'S AMAZING TO SEE IT THEY
GET OUT.
FROM DOING A CRIME WHEN THEY
COMMIT ANOTHER CRIME OUR
OFFICERS TAKEN TO FRESNO THERE
OUT BEFORE OUR OFFICERS GET HOME.
SO WORK THAT'S IT DID CONSTANT
DEL THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH SORT
TRYING TO GET MORE OFFICERS ON
THE STREET.
I RAN AGAINST TAXES ARE NOT
ATTACKS GUY I GOT IN DEFEATING
MEASURE P.. TOM SIMS I GOT IN
AND SING THE FOUR MILLION THAT
WE'RE IN THE HALL I SAID HEY WE
DO SOMETHING SO PERHAPS AND
SALES TAX ON THAT WE HAD
PRIORITIES WHAT THE SALES TAX IS
GOING TO GO FOR.
I HAD NO CLUE THAT THE ESCAPEES
COULD VOTE UNTIL WE GOT A LETTER
FROM DAYS AND THEY HAD A LIST OF
DEMANDS THAT WERE NOT IN LINE
WITH OUR PRIORITIES. AS YOU GUYS
KNOW CITIES ARE NOT PERMITTED TO
USE CITY STAFF FOR CITY TIME TO
GO OUT IN THE LOBBY ON SOMETHING
ON BEHALF WE CAN ONLY TELL
EXACTLY. WHAT A THE PRIORITY
LIST WAS WHICH WE DID SEND THEM
BACK ADD THAT PRIORITY LIST?
THEY'RE UNHAPPY WITH THAT A SO
ALL OF THEM WELL A LOT OF THE
MAJORITY OF THEM VOTED AGAINST
ARE MEASURE. NAM TO BEGIN WITH
HEY CITIZENS VOTED YOU KNOW.
I DID NOT KNOW THAT THE MAJORITY
OF THE NO VOTES CAME FROM THAT
AREA. A ONCE WE DID SOME
RESEARCH BECAUSE I WANT TO FIND
OUT EXACTLY WHERE THE VOTES CAME
FROM THAT SAID NO BECAUSE I
THOUGHT WELL YOU KNOW WE HAD
ABOUT A FIFTY PERCENT RATE IN
ALL AREAS.
.
WHEN WE FOUND OUT THIS THE STATE
HOSPITAL AREA WAS SEVENTY ONE
PERCENT AND AGAINST THIS AND ALL
THE REST OF OUR DISTRICTS FOR
ABOUT FIFTY PERCENT. WE SING
THIS WAY SO WE START LOOKING
INTO LAW.
ARE THESE ARE THE PEOPLE OUT
THERE ALLOWED VOTE SO WE STARTED
SPECIFICALLY LOOK AT THE
DOMICILE LAW SECTION THREE FORTY
NINE.
WORD STATES THAT THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE FIX THEIR INTENSE
REMAIN AND THEIR INTENT TO
RETURN IF AN ABSENCE.
I SEE THAT PROBABLY TWO OF THESE
THINGS THAT THERE IS ABSOLUTELY
NO CAPABILITY FOR THEM TO RETURN
TO THAT IF THERE APPS ON THAT
SCENARIO.
AND.
.
NONE OF THOSE PEOPLE ARE FROM
KALANGA.
SO.
I THINK THE CURRENT LAW AS IT
SITS.
TOM IS IT IS IT IS IS A GOOD LAW
BUT I THINK IT NEEDS TO BE
CLARIFIED WERE CURRENTLY GOING
TO COURT BECAUSE WE CHALLENGE
THOSE VOTES. BASED ON A ELECTION
CODE THREE FORTY NINE AND
SECTION TO CUT TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE.
NOTHING AGAINST THE PEOPLE OUT
THERE AT ALL.
YOU KNOW HOWEVER I CAN TELL YOU
THAT OUR COMMUNITIES
ARE LIVID THE WHOLE CENTRAL
VALLEY IS UNHAPPY WITH THIS.
ON MY WAY UP HERE I ASKED PEOPLE.
WHAT THEY THOUGHT ABOUT YOU KNOW
THE ESCAPEES BEEN ALLOWED TO
VOTE I DIDN'T EVEN HEAR ONE
PERSON SAY THAT THEY SHOULD BE
ALLOWED TO VOTE PERIOD MUCH LESS
IN OUR LOCAL ELECTIONS WHEN THEY
HEARD THAT THEY SWUNG THAT OUR
TAX?
YOU KNOW PEOPLE WERE REALLY
UNHAPPY ABOUT THAT SO I THINK
THIS IS A MINORITY AMOUNTS OF
PEOPLE THAT DEFINITELY THE
VOTING RIGHTS PROTECTED. BUT I'D
LIKE TO SEE IT FOR OUR CITIZENS
PROTECT AT THE SAME TIME AND
KALANGA HOUSING ALL OF A LOT A
LOT OR IF NOT ALL OF THESE. A S.
B. PEAS I THINK THAT THIS IS A.
HOW IT'S THAT MY UBER DRIVER ON
THE WAY HERE PUT IT HE SAID THIS
IS UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES? AND
SO I DISLIKE THEIR TWO WAY TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO IS THAT WE CAN
FIX THESE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES AND THE CITY OF
KALANGA THAT'S VERY EASY TO DO
WE GO BACK TO OUR. AND THE
PEOPLE COME TO US WE MAKE
COMMITMENTS TO OUR ALLIES FROM
EGGMAN INSTRUCT BELLS WOULD WE
FIX THOSE THINGS AND SACRAMENTO
I'M HERE TO DO THAT EXACT THING.
AND I'M HOPING THAT YOU GUYS.
WILL YOU KNOW LOOK AT THE
SCENARIO AND SAY HEY YOU KNOW
KALANGA HAS DONE A LOT FOR THE
STATE YOU KNOW WE'RE JUST TRYING
TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THESE WITH
THESE THINGS IN THAT. YOU KNOW
THE CURRENT LAW AS IT SITS ON.
IT'S VERY CLEAR BUT WE WOULD
WE'RE ASKING A TO SUPPORT AB.
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY NINE AND
SUPPORT OF THE AROUND THE BILL I
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS RON RAMSEY CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER FROM COLLECTED
GREAT.
HELLO THE ELECTION COMMITTEE I
MY NAME IS RON RAMSEY AND THE
CITY COUNCILMAN FROM THE CITY OF
COALINGA. AND I'M ALSO TREASURER
OF A CAP IT'S ERIC CALIFORNIA
CITIES ALLIED FOR PUBLIC SAFETY.
AND.
WE JUMPED RIGHT ON THIS THAT AS
THEY CAP THERE'S ABOUT TWENTY
CITIES AND ALL OVER THE STATE
THAT. ARE LOOKING AT THAT'S WERE
LOOKING AT. ALL ASPECTS OF THIS
STUFF.
.
YEP WERE LOOKING THE DOMICILE TO
A PERSON OF. THE I THINK YOU ALL
KNOW THIS FROM JUST.
REPEATING HEAD BUT A PERSON WHO
LEAVES HIS OR HER DOMICILE ARE.
HER HOME TO GO TO ANOTHER
PRECINCT FOR TEMPORARY PURPOSE
WITH THE INTENT OF RETURNING
THERE'S NOT LOSE THEIR DOMICILE.
SIMILARLY. A THE PERSON DOES NOT
GAIN GAIN A DOMICILE.
IN ANY PRECINCT IN WHICH THAT
HERE SHE COMES TO FOR A
TEMPORARY PURPOSE.
WITHOUT INTENDING TO MAKE AT.
THE PRECINCT HIS OR HER HOME.
TO ACQUIRE NEW DOMICILE THEY'RE
NOT TO BE BOTH INTENT. TO
ACQUIRE A NEW DOMICILE AND THE
ACT OF REMOVAL.
THE PERSON DID GAIN. GAIN.
ADAMBA SAW BECAUSE OF HIM HIS OR
HER PRESIDENT.
IN THAT PLACE.
AND BECOME AN INMATE IS.
OR IT OR IN THE PHYLUM WHERE
PRESIDENT.
ALONG THE SAME LINES WHO'D BEEN
RECOGNIZE THAT IN.
OF THE MILITARY THE PRESIDENT OF
A MILITARY STATION WITHOUT MORE.
I CANNOT BE A STATION WHERE THE
SERVICEMAN DID DUMB DOWN THE
FILE LIST.
BECAUSE SERVICEMEN THE SUBJECT
TO THE ORDERS OF THEIR SUPERIOR
OFFICERS.
A.
IN THAT THE MARRIAGE OF THORTON
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO. A THERE'S A
WHOLE WHOLE STRING APPEAR.
A CASES ON IT
SIMILARLY IN THE CASE OF.
AT PATIENT VOTERS ARE UNDER A
COURT ORDER.
HERE THEIR COMMITTED THEY HAVE
NO CONTROL THERE FREEDOM OF
WHERE THEY CAN LIVE SO THEY
DON'T HAVE AN ANTENNA.
SO THEY HAVE TO GO WHERE THERE
TOLD HIM.
SO THEY DON'T HAVE THAT INTO.
THE POWER TO CHANGE THAT.
AND UNTIL THEY DO ARE THEY CAN
WE DON'T CARE IF THEY VOTE.
IT OUT BUT THEY SHOULDN'T BE
ABLE TO VOTE FROM A.
WHERE THEY ARE?
BECAUSE.
IT'S IT CHANGES ALL THE TIME
SOMETIMES THEY'RE TAKEN OUT OF
THE HOSPITAL INTAKE AND OTHER
PLACES SO THAT'S NOT A PERMANENT
DOMICILE FOR.
I I I I I JUST RETIRED FROM
THERE.
CORRECTIONS.
THEN I WORKED AT THE STATE
HOSPITAL AND I AND I WORKED AT
THAT STATE PRISON BOTH AND I
WASN'T TRANSPORTATION.
AND WE DID TRANSFEROWN BOTH
BOTH PLACES.
AND IF A SERVICEMAN CANNOT HAVE
A DOMICILE AHEAD OF THEIR BABIES.
WHY CAN AN INMATE FLORA A
PATIENT?
HAVE.
IT'S NOT RIGHT.
IF A UP SERVICEMEN CAN'T DO IT.
WHY CAN HAPPEN CONVICTED?
CRIMINAL OR A PERSON THAT'S.
IN THERE TO SEE IF THEY'RE GOING
TO RECOMMIT. WHY SHOULD THEY
HAVE THE SAME RIGHTS
AND WITH THAT?
I I WOULD LIKE YOU TO A.
LOOK FOR HIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
AND THE MORNING SUZANNE FACTS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA CITIES
ALLIED WITH PUBLIC SAFETY IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING TONYA STALLS MAYOR
PRO TEM KALANGA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SEEN KNOW ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION
.
MY ANGER I'M LEGISLATIVE
ATTORNEY WITH THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA GOOD MORNING AND WE
ARE HERE RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION.
WE UNDERSTAND AND EMPATHIZE WITH
THE FUNDING ISSUES IN COALINGA
AND WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
CONSTITUENCY HERE MIGHT NOT BE
THE MOST SYMPATHETIC POPULATION.
BUT WE THINK CHANGE IN THE
VOTING RIGHTS OF JUST ONE
CONSTITUENCY BASED ON. THE
OUTCOME OF ONE ELECTION IS ON
SOUND PUBLIC POLICY. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE SPELL
ONLY TARGETS ONE SET OF PATIENTS
AT THE STATE HOSPITAL NOT.
THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN ADJUDICATED
A SEXUALLY VIOLENT PREDATOR NOT
THE OTHER PATIENTS THAT RESIDE
THERE. ITS MARGIN OF THAT THESE
ARE PATIENTS THEIR CIVILLY
COMMITTED NOT CRIMINALLY
COMMITTED LIBERTIES SERVE THEIR
CRIMINAL SENSE AND LIKE MANY
OTHERS OF CRIMINAL CONVICTIONS
IN THE STATE. THEY HAVE VOTING
RIGHTS AFTERWARDS AS LONG AS
THEY MEET THE OTHER VOTING
CRITERIA. ALSO POINTED OUT THAT
THESE ARE LENGTHY CIVIL
COMMITMENTS
AS THE ANALYSIS POINTS OUT SINCE
TWO THOUSAND SIX ABOUT A
THOUSAND OF THESE PATIENTS HAVE
BEEN COMMITTED TO THE STATE
HOSPITAL. IN A DOZEN YEARS LATER
EIGHTY PERCENT OF THEM REMAIN
THERE SO THEY'RE IN THIS
HOSPITAL FOR A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF TIME.
UNDER CURRENT LAW THEY CAN
REGISTER TO VOTE AND THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY CAN RESIDE
FROM BUT THE SPELL ONLY LIMITS
THEM TO THAT REGION. AND WE
THINK THAT'S ON SOUND POLICY
PUBLIC POLICY THAT'S NOT WHERE
THEY LIVE THEY'RE NOT BEEN
IMPACTED BY. THE LOCAL DECISIONS
OF ELECTED OFFICIALS THEIR
ADDRESS MAY NOT PHYSICALLY EXIST
ANYMORE THEY'VE ALREADY SERVED A
CRIMINAL SENTENCE NOW THEY HAVE
A LINK THE CIVIL COMMITMENT
SIGNIFICANT TIME HAS PASSED.
THEY MAY NO LONGER HAVE FAMILY
OR COMMUNITY TIES TO THE REGION
THEY CAME FROM. IT'S ALSO%
IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT THE CITY
DID MAKE A CHOICE HERE THEY
CHOSE TO ANNEX THE HOSPITAL. AND
THAT CREATED TAX BENEFITS FOR
THE CITY BUT IT ALSO GAVE
PATIENTS AT THAT HOSPITAL THE
RIGHT TO VOTE IN THAT AREA. AND
NOW WE UNDERSTAND THE
DISSATISFACTION WITH THESE
ELECTION RESULTS BUT
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGING THE
VOTING RIGHTS OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS AS THE RESULT OF ONE
CLOSE ELECTION. WE THINK IS
UNSOUND COURSE FOR THE STATE TO
TAKE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN BERMAN
GOOD MORNING VICE CHAIRMAN
HARPER.
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY
EIGHT THIRTY NINE MY NAME IS
JANICE BALUCHI AND I'M A CIVIL
RIGHTS ATTORNEY. I'M ALSO
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
ALLIANCE FOR CONSTITUTIONAL SEX
OFFENSE LAWS WHICH IS A NON FAT
THAT'S COMPRISED OF OVER A
HUNDRED AND FIVE THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS AND
FAMILIES.
MY TESTIMONY TODAY BY THE WAY IS
IN ADDITION TO MY LETTER OF
SIMILAR TO THE COMMITTEE THAT
STATE ABLE TWENTY FIFTH.
AS CURRENTLY WRITTEN AB TWENTY
EIGHT THIRTY NINE WOULD
DISENFRANCHISE HUNDREDS OF
CALIFORNIA CITIZENS WHO ARE
PATIENTS I CALLING A STATE
HOSPITAL.
WHILE IT'S TRUE THAT ABOUT
SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT OF THE
PATIENTS.
ARE HER HAVE BEEN DESIGNATED A
SEXUALLY VIOLENT PREDATORS IT'S
ALSO TRUE THAT STATE LAW HAS
DECLARED AND CASE LAW HAS
DETERMINED THAT ALL PATIENTS
WERE NOT ON PAROLE ELIGIBLE TO
VOTE.
I IN FACT ELIGIBILITY TO VOTE IS
NOT AT ISSUE AND AB TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY NINE BUT WHAT IS AT ISSUE
IN THE BILL IS WHERE ELIGIBLE
BUT A PATIENTS MAY VOTE.
CURRENTLY PATIENTS ARE ALLOWED
TO CHOOSE THEIR OWN DOMICILE
THIS'S BEEN ESTABLISHED BY CASE
LAW FOR STUDENTS FOR MILITARY
MEMBERS PRISONERS AT CETERA.
AND BECAUSE OF THAT THE
PATIENTS OFTEN MAKE THEIR CHOICE
BASED UPON WHERE THEY WILL BE
DIRECTLY AFFECTED.
MOST PATIENTS ARE CALLING A
STATE HOSPITAL WHO ARE ELIGIBLE
TO VOTE HAVE CHOSEN THE CITY OF
COALINGA AS THEIR DOMICILE. AND
THAT'S BECAUSE MOST OF LIFT AT
THE HOSPITAL TWELVE TEN YEARS OR
LONGER. AND THEY ARE ALSO
DIRECTLY AFFECTED BY ISSUES SUCH
AS THE CITIES.
SALES TAX
IT'S THEY PAY WHEN THEY PURCHASE
FOOD CLOTHING AND ELECTRONICS AT
THE HOSPITALS RETAIL OUTLETS.
THEY'VE CHOSEN THE CITY OF
CALLING UP BECAUSE THEY NO
LONGER HAVE TIES TO THE LAST
KNOWN ADDRESS BEFORE THEY WERE
COMMITTED TO THE HOSPITAL. AND
IF THEY TRY TO VOTE AT THE LAST
KNOWN ADDRESS IT'S DOUBTFUL THAT
THE COULD EVEN QUALIFIES VOTERS
ON THAT COMMUNITY.
THE FACT IS THAT AT LEAST NINETY
FIVE PERCENT OF THE PATIENTS ARE
CALLING THE STATE HOSPITAL WILL
LIVE AT THE HOSPITAL UNTIL THEY
DIE.
NINETY FIVE PERCENT
IF THEY ARE NOT ALLOWED TO VOTE
IN THE CITY OF COALINGA THEY
WILL SUFFER TAXATION WITHOUT
REPRESENTATION. FOR THESE
REASONS WE URGE YOU ALL TO VOTE
NO ON AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY
NINE.
THANK YOU THINGS WITH.
ARM FELLOW COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
ROBERT TURNER I COME FROM FRESNO
CALIFORNIA I LIVED STATE
HOSPITAL AS A PATIENT FOR SIX
YEARS.
AND WAS RELEASED UNCONDITIONALLY.
WITH OUR FIFTY DARTS MY NAME AND
IT UP IN ALMOST SHALL TURN
FRESNO.
I'M CURRENTLY WORKING WITH THE
INTERNAL REVENUE SERVICE THERE
OUR I WAS THE LEE A COMMUNITY
LIAISON FOR THAT DETAINEE
AMERICANS FOR CIVIC EQUALITY OR
DAIS.
IN THE RUN UP PRIOR TO THE
ELECTION I WAS THE.
I INTERMEDIARY WHO WAS.
TALKING TO THE CITY MANAGER.
AND COMMUNICATING BETWEEN.
THEM INDIA PATIENTS IN THE
HOSPITAL.
.
FIFTY FIVE PERCENT OF THE THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY REGISTER VOTERS
TO THE HOSPITAL CAST BALLOTS.
COMPARED TO TWENTY ONE PERCENT
IN THE CITY.
EVEN SO FIFTY OF THE HUNDREDS
SEVENTY SEVEN PATIENTS WHO VOTED.
WERE FOR THE MEASURE.
SO THE PATIENT MANY OF THE
PATIENTS WERE SYMPATHETIC TO THE
CITY'S NEEDS.
AND VOTE.
MATTER.
WHILE IT'S TRUE THAT THE PATIENT
VOTE TIP THE BALANCE AGAINST THE
TAX INCREASE IS SELDOM MENTIONED
THAT WITHOUT THE PATIENT VOTE
THE MEASURE WOULD HAVE ONLY
BARELY PASSED BY FORTY VOTES.
IN THE CITY WITHOUT THE WITHOUT
THE HOSPITAL VOTES.
IT DID NOT HAVE THE OVERWHELMING
SUPPORT OF THE CITY AND YET THE
HOUSE WILL PATIENTS HAVE BEEN
SCAPEGOATED. FOR MEASURE SEES
LOTS AND THE CITY IS SUING IN
COURT TO DISQUALIFY THE PATIENTS
VOTES REVERSED THE RESULT THE
ELECTION SO THEY CAN HAVE THEIR
TAX MONEY.
PATIENTS PAY SALES TAX WILL
ARE ON PURCHASE AT THE HOSPIAL
THIS WOULD ADD TO
THE PENNY.
TO THE DOLLAR THAT'S TRUE AND
AND THIS IS BEING CHARACTERIZED
AS PENNIES ON AYE I DON'T
HAMBURGER COST.
BUT I N. AND PEOPLE DO LIKE TO
AND PATIENTS ALIKE GO TO THE
GRILL. ARE THEY PREFER THAT TO
THE CAFETERIA FARE AND MANY
CASES SOLAT MONEY IS SPENT THEIR.
SOME OF THE PATIENTS MANY OF THE
PATIENTS ONLY GET TWELVE FIFTY A
MONTH.
THAT'S THEIR ALLOWANCE OTHER
PATIENTS GET MONEY SENATE FROM
OUTSIDE.
THEY CAN ONLY HAVE UP TO FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS THEY SHARE THAT
WITH A LOT OF OTHER PATIENTS
TAKING OF THE GRAIL. AND AND
THEY CAN BUY THINGS.
ARE.
I'VE FROM MY BY MAIL ORDER.
BOOKS TELEVISION VIDEO GAME
PLAYERS AND GAMES DVDS AND CD
PLAYERS AND DEATHS.
EVEN JEWELRY AT SOME CLOTHING
ITEMS HAVE THEIR LOUD.
THERE IS THE POTENTIAL HERE FOR
THE CITY TO GAIN THOUSANDS IF
NOT TENS OF THOUSAND DOLLARS
FROM THE PURCHASES THAT ARE MADE.
BY THE PATIENTS AT THE AT THE
HOSPITAL.
ARE WHILE I HAVE NO WAY OF
KNOWING EXACTLY HOW LITTLE OR
HOW LARGE THIS MATT WOULD BE.
FOR THE CITY NEVERTHELESS
THERE'S A THERE'S IMPORTANT
PRINCIPLE STAKE HERE.
WHAT AB TWO EIGHTY NINE IS
ATTEMPTING TO DO IS TO ENSURE
THAT THE CITY OF COALINGA CAN
TAX THE CIVIL DETAINEES?
THE STATE HOSPITAL WHILE
ALLOWING THEM NO SAY IN WHO WILL
DETERMINE HOW THOSE MONIES ARE
SPENT.
THIS IS TAXATION WITHOUT
REPRESENTATION PUT IT SUCCINCTLY.
AND THAT'S WHY THE REASONS WHY
THIS COUNTRY DECLARED ITS
INDEPENDENCE.
THE BILL AUTHORED AT THE BEHEST
OF THE CITY COALINGA IS
PROFOUNDLY UNAMERICAN BOTH IN
ITS EFFECT AND IN THIS INTENT.
THE CITY IS TRYING TO
DISENFRANCHISE A GROUP OF ITS
OWN CITIZENS.
BECAUSE THEY DO NOT LIKE THE WAY
THAT THEY VOTED AND CITY
ELECTION.
I RECOMMEND THAT THE COMMITTEE
REJECT THIS BILL.
AND.
IF I MAY ADD THERE IS A SOLUTION
IF THEY DON'T WANT.
THE PATIENTS TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE CITY ELECTION AND THAT IS TO
TAKE THAT SQUARE MILE THAT
INCLUDES THE PRISON. AND
HOSPITAL AND REMOVE IT FROM THE
CITY IT'S AN OUTLIER.
BUT THAT WOULD IMMEDIATELY
DROPPED THE POPULATION THAT CITY
BY FIVE THOUSAND.
AND I DON'T THINK THEY WANT TO
DO THAT.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
EVELYN I'LL HASN'T DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WE ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH THE ACLU THE
OUTCOME OF AN ELECTION SHOULD.
BE THE BASIS FOR CHANGING OF A
PARTICULAR CLASSES
DOMICILE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN OF MEMBERS
NICK BROKE OUT HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL FOR THE REASONS STATED
BY THE ACLU.
THANK YOU.
YOUR MIND TO FROM SACRAMENTO
YEAH OPPOSES SPIEL. THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ROBERT STERLING AND I
AM SVP
I HAVE BEEN OUT FIFTEEN YEARS I
WAS RELEASED BY JURY TRIAL IN
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY FIFTEEN
YEARS AGO.
I REPRESENT A NUMBER OF FRIENDS
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN ESCAPEES IT
THE HOSPITAL THAT STARTED AT
ATASCADERO HONOR NOW TRANSFERRED.
TO COALINGA.
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO SAY
REMEMBER PLEASE WITH THEIR
PATIENTS ARE NOT PRISONERS.
THEY HAVE RIGHTS THOSE RIGHTS
SOME OF THEM ARE TO VOTE.
AND THEY ARE GOING TO BE OR ARE.
MOST OF THEM
SO THE IDEA THAT THERE'S ANOTHER
RESIDENTS OR PLACE FOR THEM TO
GO.
ISRAEL SO WHEN YOU TAKE AWAY THE
RIGHT TO VOTE TAKEAWAY MANY
THINGS THAT THEY MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU.
SHERRI HARLOW SACRAMENTO COUNTY
ALSO AXLE BOARD MEMBER AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ON MY NAME IS ARE
UX GRILLING COME FROM WOODLAND
HILLS CALIFORNIA ON OPPOSED BY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
MICHAEL ESCOBAR SACRAMENTO
COUNTY.
AND.
I'M ALSO REGISTRANT.
I KNOW PEOPLE AT THE HOSPITAL
AND.
.
YEAH I OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
ROGER HUNNICUTT BUSINESSMEN FROM
MODESTO STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AN AMERICAN TAXATION
WITHOUT REPRESENTATION THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NINE OPENS HIS ME SIR.
PERFECTLY ALRIGHT.
MY NAME IS HOWARD BROKE I.
SACRAMENTO I'M ALSO A REGISTRANT
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND I'D LIKE TO BRING A BEVERAGE
DOT COLLEGE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ABOUT YOUR HARBOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HAVE MISTER
CHAIRMAN I ALSO WANT TO EXPRESS
THEIR APPRECIATE BEING ABLE TALK
A BRIEF YOU WITH THE A CHAIR AS
WELL AS.
SOME OF THE ADVOCATE SUFFERING
COALINGA.
BUT OF COURSE WANT TO MAKE A
SOME OF THOSE POINTS ON RECORD I
HEAR IN THE PUBLIC FORUM. AYE IS
WELL I IN I DO THINK THAT THERE
ARE SOME A POTENTIAL ALTERNATIVE
SIDE TO WHAT TO THIS AS A AS A
BILL.
BOB OF ONE OF THE ISSUES SIDE
THAT I THINK AS BEEN BROUGHT UP
AND SHOULD BE A KIND OF
FLUSHABLE BIT. LIES THAT
ACCORDING TO THE STATE HOSPITALS
AYE ONE THOUSAND FIFTY EIGHT OF
THE SEXUALLY VIOLENT PREDATORS I
HAVE BEEN COMMITTED TO CALLING A
STATE HOSPITAL SINCE TWO
THOUSAND SIX. UP BUT ONLY TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY OR TWENTY
PERCENT HAVE BEEN RELEASED
SORT APPEARS THAT A VAST
MAJORITY THESE PERSONS WILL LIVE
AT THE HOSPITAL FOR A LONG TIME.
AND PROBABLY FOR THE REST THEIR
LIVES I THINK OF WHERE THE
TESTIMONIES WASN'T UP TO NINETY
FIVE PERCENT OF THE FOLKS OUT
MAYBE A FIT INTO THIS CATEGORY.
AYE SO THE QUESTION I WOULD POSE
IS OUT WHY SHOULD THEY BE
REQUIRED TO VOTE IN A PRECINCT
IN WHICH THEY NO LONGER LIVE.
I AND THEY ARE HIGHLY UNLIKELY
TO RETURN.
I BELIEVE THAT THIS MEASURE IS
CONSISTENT WITH AN ACTION THAT
THIS COMMITTEE ITSELF TOOK JUST
LAST MONTH.
WHEN IT PASSED AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY TWO WHICH IS NOW CLEARED
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR AS WELL.
WHICH REQUIRES THE CDC ARE TO
PROVIDE INFORMATION TO THE
CITIZENS REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION REGARDING THE LAST
KNOWN PLACE OF ADDRESS OF EACH
IN INMATE WHO WAS IN A FACILITY
THAT IS UNDER THE CDC OURS
CONTROL. SO THAT THE INMATES CAN
BE COUNTED IN THE COMMUNITY THAT
THEY CAME FROM.
IF THEY'RE COUNTED FOR THE
PURPOSES OF DECIDING WHO THEIR
ELECTED REPRESENTATIVES ARE.
I BELIEVE THAT THEY CAN VOTE IN
THAT SAME DOMICILE. IF WE AS A
STATE IN THIS COMMITTEE HAS
TAKEN THAT ACTION I BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS CONSISTENT. WITH THAT
PREVIOUS MEASURE.
AND I APPRECIATE OTHER POINTS ON
THAT AND THAT'S PART OF WHY IT
ACTUALLY ARGUED IN OPPOSITION TO
THAT PARTICULAR BILL EVEN THOUGH
I RECOGNIZE THAT IT PASSED.
BUT SPECIFICALLY IN THIS
SITUATION.
VOTERS IN THE CALLING A STATE
HOSPITAL ARE DIRECTLY AFFECTED
BY LOCAL SALES TAXES ARE WHEN
THEY BUY GOODS IN THE HOSPITAL
IS TESTIFIED HERE IN THE
CONVENIENCE STORE THE RESTAURANT.
BY THE COPY CENTER AYE IN OTHER
BUSINESSES UP WHY SHOULDN'T THEY
BE ABLE TO VOTE ON A TAX MEASURE
THAT DIRECTLY AFFECTS HOW MUCH
THEY PAY ON THOSE GOODS. WILL I
I ACTUALLY ONE OF REFERENCE IF I
CAN THE CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS
TESTIMONY I THOUGHT IT WAS.
POWERFUL THAT FROM OUR SERVICE
MEMBERS ARE NOT US AFFORDED THE
SAME OPPORTUNITY.
THAT THEY MAY HAVE BEEN HOUSED
IN A COMMUNITY THAT PASSED A
SALES TAX MEASURE THAT THEY
COULD NOT VOTE ON. BUT THEY
THEMSELVES WILL ALSO HAVE TO PAY
FOR THAT TAX.
SO I WOULD ALIGN MY COMMENTS IN
RESPONSE TO THAT QUESTION TO THE
CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS COMMENTS.
AND I RESPECTFULLY SEE THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THOSE IN THAT
SOMEONE WHO SERVES ON A MILITARY
BASE AYE IS IN A MUCH MORE
TEMPORARY SITUATION WHERE IS I
THINK THAT.
IN THIS SITUATION AYE THE
TESTIMONY AND THE.
THE BACKGROUND HIS.
I TESTED THAT FOLKS ONCE THEY'RE
LIVING HERE TEN TEN TO LIVE HERE
WITHIN MABILLE ALLOW ME ONE
CHARTER STEP BECAUSE.
THE MAYOR'S.
POINT SHOULDN'T BE LOST THAT.
WE HAVE A CITY IN MY COUNTY THAT
REALLY HAS DONE EVERYTHING THAT
THE STATE HAS ASKED OF.
THAT IS ATTEMPTING TO.
WHILE WE HAVE MANY NIMBY ISMS
NOT IN MY BACKYARD WE HAD A CITY
THAT WAS WILLING.
AND HAS HOUSED A STATE HOSPITAL
IN OUR COMMUNITY.
BUT THIS IS A CITY THAT IS
STRUGGLING RIGHT NOW OUR
HOSPITAL CLOSED THIS WEEK.
AND WERE STRUGGLING AS A CITY TO
RETAIN THE POLICE OFFICERS AND
FIREFIGHTERS THAT ARE NEEDED.
FOR OUR COMMUNITY TO THRIVE AND
WERE TRYING TO FIND SOLUTIONS
AND. REALLY WOULD ASK THAT THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE LOOK
AT THE FACT THAT THIS IS A
DISTRICT BILL.
ONE THAT WILL AFFECT.
BUT MEMBERS FROM MY COMMUNITY
AND.
AS THEIR ADVOCATE I'M TRYING TO
FIGHT FOR.
THE ALL MEMBERS OF MY COMMUNITY
AND I BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL
HELPS US TO DO THAT.
IN AND I DO APPRECIATE THAT ONE
THING AYE I WAS JUST REMINDED OF
THAT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TWO
WHY BE DISTINCT ABOUT. AYE IS OF
ON A MILITARY BASE SIDE. PERHAPS
FOR THE REASONS WHY P. X. AND
OTHER LOCATIONS ARE SO POPULAR
IS BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE SALES
TAX WHEN THEY'RE ON THAT FEDERAL
FEDERAL MILITARY BASE.
BOB BUT I THINK ANOTHER POINT
I'D THAT WAS BROUGHT UP AYE IS
VERY.
WORTH EXPLORING I IN TERMS OF
POTENTIALLY THE.
THE OVERALL APPROACH TO THIS
ISSUE AND THAT'S THAT TWENTY
YEARS AGO THE LEGISLATURE
ACTUALLY WAS ASKED TO PASS A
BILL. A TO GRANT THE CITY
COALINGA SPECIAL PERMISSION.
ANNEX IN NONCONTIGUOUS PARCEL OF
LAND THAT INCLUDED THE STATE
PRISON AYE EVEN THOUGH IT WAS
FOUR MILES AWAY. IN ORDER TO
PERHAPS BOOST OUR THE POPULATION
COUNT FOR THE CITY.
AND THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR ANALYSIS
UP FOR THAT BILL EXPLAIN. EITHER
A PORTION OF BOTH THE VEHICLE
LICENSE FUND FEES AND THE
VEHICLE FUEL TAXES ARE ALLOCATED
TO CITIES ON A PER CAPITA BASIS.
AND BY ANNEXING STATE
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES AND
THEREBY BRINGING PRISON
RESIDENTS UNDER THE UMBRELLA OF
THE CITY'S LOCAL POPULATION.
THE CITY WOULD BE ENTITLED TO A
LARGER PORTION OF THESE
SUBVENTION. AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT I WAS VERY INVOLVED IN WHEN
I WORKED OU FOR THE COUNTY OF
ORANGE AND SAW HOW. ORANGE
COUNTY PUBLIC WORKS BENEFITTED
FROM.
THE POPULATION NOW THAT THEY
HAD AND HOW INDIVIDUAL CITIES
BENEFITTED FROM THE BAR
POPULATION THEY HAD SU COALINGA.
HAS BENEFITED FINANCIALLY FOR
LAST TWENTY YEARS FROM BEING
ABLE TO COUNT PRISONERS AT THE
PLEASANT VALLEY STATE PRISON.
AND PATIENTS FROM THE COALINGA
STATE A STATE HOSPITAL IN THEIR
POPULATION COUNT.
HAVING RECEIVED THE FINANCIAL
BENEFITS OF COUNTING VOTERS AT
THE HOT.
WHY SHOULD THE CITY NOW BE
ALLOWED TO TREAT THEM AS NON
RESIDENTS
WITHOUT VOTING RIGHTS AYE IN
TAKE THEM OFF THE VOTER ROLLS
AND TRANSFORM TO OTHER LOCATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE? I JUST
BECAUSE OF POLITICAL LEADERSHIP
BUT DOES NOT LIKE HOW THEY VOTED
ON A MEASURE.
WELL THINK THAT'S AN APPROPRIATE
QUESTION BOMBS.
IF WE'RE LOOKING AT A TIME LINE
THOUGH I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THE STATE
HOSPITAL WAS NOT PRESENT WHEN
THAT ANNEXATION HAPPENED.
AND SO NOR WORD THE VOTING
RIGHTS RESTORED UNTIL THE
SUPERIOR COURT HAD RESTORED THEM
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN.
SO WE HAVE TWO VARIABLES THAT
HAVE CHANGED SINCE THAT
ANNEXATION.
THE SECOND AND MORE PRESSING
CONCERN IN TERMS OF THE CITY WAS
STARING WITH THEIR FINANCIAL
SHORTFALLS.
HOW DO WE ADDRESS THE ISSUE
THAT'S BEFORE US AND THEY WERE
TRYING TO DEAL WITH THIS?
NOW WHETHER THE CITY SHOULD ON
AN AXE ISN'T DECISION THAT THE
LOCALS CAN MAKE.
WHAT? I WANT TO SAY IS THAT NONE
OF THAT WOULD HAVE HAPPENED IN
THE TIMELINE THAT WOULD HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO KEEP THE POLICE
OFFICERS AND FIREFIGHTERS. THAT
WERE NEEDED FOR THE CITY THAT
THE TIMELINE FOR THE ON
ANNEXATION IF THAT WAS A CHOICE
THEY WISH TO PURSUE. A WOULD NOT
HAVE ALLOWED THEM TO RETAIN
THOSE OFFICERS.
AND.
MISTER MERITED YOUR I ABSOLUTELY
DID I'M I WANT TO POINT OUT THAT.
YOU CAN LOOK AT THINGS AS
BENEFITS.
BUT
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE AMOUNT OF
PUBLIC SAFETY THAT'S REQUIRED
WHEN YOU HAVE A STATE HOSPITAL
AND YOU HAVE THE RELATIVES GUY
COMING YOU HAVE A PRISON. AND
YOU HAVE THE RELATIVES COMING
AND A LOT OF OUR COMMUNITY
STATED.
WE DIDN'T WANT THE EITHER OF
THESE INSTITUTIONS COMING
BECAUSE OF THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES THAT COME.
I JUST CHECK WE GET ABOUT TWELVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR FROM
THOSE GOT GAS TAXES AND STUFF
LIKE THAT TO COME THROUGH THERE.
UP I WOULD GIVE THAT MONEY UP IN
A HEARTBEAT EVEN THOUGH THAT
WERE NOT TOM.
.
THIS MY PERSONAL OPINION EVEN
THOUGH THAT WE ARE ARE HORRIBLE
POSITION TECH DEBT WISE BUT IF
IT'S THE RECOMMENDATION OF THIS
COMMITTEE TO ARM.
YOU KNOW DE ANNEX THAT AREA.
I WOULD SAY THAT THAT'S AKIN TO
GERRYMANDERING ON OUR SIDE IF WE
WERE TO DO THAT WE WOULD BE IN
THE EXACT SAME BOAT YOU DO LOOK
AT US AND SAYING SAYING. HEY WHY
ARE YOU TRYING TO CUT THESE
PEOPLE OUT SO WE'RE NOT GONNA
BUILD A WIN FOR LOSING. AND AND
HERE'S ANOTHER THING THAT OUT
BUT I WOULD STATE ABOUT.
THE STATE HOSPITAL BEING OUT
THERE IS THAT AS YOU EVERYONE'S
HAS STATED ALREADY YOU KNOW WE
TOOK THAT SONG HALF OF OUR
CITIZENS I BELIEVE DIDN'T WANT
THAT SCENARIO. UP THE STATE
HOSPITAL GETS A TON OF ITS WATER
ALL OF ITS WATER FROM CITY
KALANGA WHAT HAPPENS IF THEY'RE
NO LONGER IN THE CITY. WHERE
THEY GET THEIR WATER RINSE WHEN
THE WHEN THE STATE COMES AND
SAYS HEY WE NEED TO CUT OUT
WATER FUNDS WE NEED TO TAKE OUT
THE DAY REFERRED TO DROUGHT? YOU
KNOW THAT ARE OUTLINED
BUSINESSES IN AREAS WERE THE
FIRST PEOPLE THAT WERE CUT OFF
WHERE THEY'RE GONNA GET THEIR
WATER FROM.
THAT'S GONNA BE ANOTHER BIG
SCENARIO I THINK THE CITY AND
THE CITIZENS WOULD DEFINITELY BE
INTO DE ANNEXING THAT AREA A
LISTENING TO OUR CITIZENS AROUND
THAT WOULD BE THAT COULD BE AN
OPTION HOWEVER. I THINK THAT.
WE WOULD LIKE YOU KNOW SOME
KIND OF A DIRECTION TO DO THAT
BECAUSE OF THAT WAS GIVEN TO US.
THEN IT WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO COME
BACK AROUND AND SAY THAT WE'RE
GERRYMANDERING THE SITUATION AND
I THINK THAT THAT THAT THAT THAT
PATIENTS THAT ARE OUT THERE
ACTUALLY DO BENEFIT. FROM THE
SERVICES THAT WE PROVIDE THAT
WE'RE NO LONGER GOING TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE.
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT OUR
TAX IS SPELLED IN BECAUSE OF THE
TAX THAT THE FACT THAT THE STATE
DECIDED NOT TO.
DO AT THE HOSPITAL ANYMORE OUR
CITIZENS BILL LIKE THAT WE'RE
BOONDOGGLE AND US THEY SAID THEY
WOULD HIRE SIXTY PERCENT OF THE
PEOPLE THERE'S ABOUT THIRTY
PERCENT OF THE PEOPLE. THEY SAID
THE PEOPLE COME TO LIVE HERE VAN
POOLS BY TAX BONDS ARE TAKING
PEOPLE AWAY FROM OUR COMMUNITY.
THIS IS NOT BEEN A BENEFIT TO
OUR COMMUNITY I JUST ONE POINT
THAT OUT I DON'T WANT ANYONE
THINKING OF THIS A BENEFIT THIS
IS NOT A BENEFIT EXCEPT FOR THE
JOBS. AND THE OPPORTUNITIES FROM
THAT BUT GETS WET WHEN THIRTY
PERCENT OF THE PEOPLE ARE ONLY
WORKING LOCAL AND THE REMAINDER
OF THEM ARE WORKING ELSEWHERE.
THAT'S NOT SUCH A BIG BENEFIT
AND I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO POINT
OUT THAT EVERYONE THAT WORKS
THERE PAYS THAT SALES TAX
EVERYONE THAT COMES THROUGH
KALANGA PAYS THAT SELLS TAX. SO
IT'S NOT TAXATION WITHOUT
REPRESENTATION AND A LOT OF
THESE PEOPLE THAT WERE OUT THERE
ACTUALLY THERE WERE THERE IN
LIEU. OF A SENTENCE
THING I LIKE THAT THEY ACTUALLY
FINISH THEIR STUFF SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
SO MISS CHAIRED THAT THE LAST
THING THAT I WANTED TO TO
MENTION.
I DON'T THINK THE COMMITTEE
WOULD REALLY BE IN A POSITION TO
MAKE YOU A SUGGESTION
SUGGESTIONS ARE DIRECTIONS BUT I
CAN MAKE.
SUGGESTIONS ONE IS ARE THIS
ELECTION THAT'S IN CONCERN WAS A
SPECIAL ELECTION IN AN ODD YEAR.
I OBVIOUSLY HAD VERY LOW TURNOUT
EXCEPT FOR ONE PARTICULAR
COMMUNITY THAT SEEM TO HAVE OVER
FIFTY FIVE PERCENT TURNOUT WHICH
WAS THE FOLKS AT THE STATE
HOSPITAL.
I STILL HOLDING THE ELECTION
AGAIN IN PERHAPS A REGULAR
GENERAL ELECTION OR REGULAR
PRIMARY ELECTION.
WOULD ACTUALLY HAVE A BROADER
RANGE OF PARTICIPATION BY THE
PEOPLE OF CALLING AND I THINK
THAT THAT PROBABLY OUGHT TO BE.
THE FIRST PATH I'VE FOR THE
CITY TO LOOK AT IT COULD HAVE
BEEN JUNE FIFTH BUT THEY WERE
TOO LATE FOR THE DEADLINES ON
THAT BUT OF COURSE NOVEMBER SIX
IS AN OPPORTUNITY.
I THEIR QUESTIONS WERE BROUGHT
UP IN TERMS OF.
THE LAW ON THE DOMICILE
QUESTION I IN WHAT REALLY
CONSTITUTES ADONIS OUT THAT
SOUNDS LIKE A QUESTION FOR THE
COURTS AND THE QUESTION I FOR
POTENTIAL LITIGATION BY THE CITY.
OUGHT TO SETTLE THAT ISSUE WHICH
WOULDN'T NEED ACTION BY BY THE
STATE LEGISLATURE
I NO WOULDN'T BE POPULAR WITH
THE MAJORITY.
WITHIN THIS BODY BUT MAYBE
HAVING A DISCUSSION OF.
IS IT APPROPRIATE TO HAVE A
VOTING RIGHTS FOR.
FELONS.
WHO ARE SEXUALLY VIOLENT
PREDATORS EVEN AFTER THEIR?
THEIR SENTENCES AYE IS A TIME
FOR THAT KIND OF DISCUSSION BUT
I THINK THAT ALSO ONE OF THINGS
THAT WAS BROUGHT UP AND I'M GLAD
PEOPLE ARE ACT BY DISCUSSING
THIS. IS IS IT APPROPRIATE.
TO MOVE FORWARD WITH A DOZEN
CORPORATION IF INDEED.
THIS FACILITY ISN'T PART OF THE
COMMUNITY I I WOULD. AGREE THAT.
YOU YOU STILL HAVE A SITUATION
OF IT'S NOT A PART OF THE CITY
COALINGA IT'S A PART OF THE
COUNTY THEY STILL BE REPRESENTED
BY COUNTY SUPERVISORS SIX ATRA.
IN TERMS OF THEIR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ESPECIALLY SINCE THIS
PARCEL AYE IS NOT CONTIGUOUS OUT
WITH THE REST OF THE CITY OF.
OF COALINGA SO WITH THAT I
THINK THAT THERE ARE OTHER
POTENTIAL SOLUTIONS AND
POTENTIAL AVENUES TO BE ABLE TO
WERE. I TO ADDRESS THESE
CONCERNS BUT I DO APPRECIATE
THEM AND I. AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT THE STRUGGLE THE COMMUNITY
IS HAVING AND SO I I WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE WHO ARE
ADVOCATES FOR THIS BILL
UNDERSTAND THAT.
THAT I DO UNDERSTAND THAT GIVEN
WHAT ONE SECOND SIR.
THANK YOU VICE ARBOR ON IT DO
YOU CAN MAKE SURE YOU HAVE A
CHANCE FOR APPLYING A SECOND BUT
I KNOW WE OUGHT TO BE AT THE
REPLACE THAT ONCE A MISTER
CALDERON. THAT THINK YOU I'LL BE
VERY QUICK. IT YOU KNOW I I
STRUGGLE BECAUSE I I HAVE TO TWO
SIDES OF THIS MONTH THE FOR SIDE
IS I KNOW WHO YOU ARE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARAMBULA I KNOW YOUR
HEART I KNOW YOU'RE A GOOD
PERSON. AND I KNOW THAT YOU ARE
FIGHTING FOR YOUR COMMUNITY AND
I KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO HAVE A
DISTRICT.
BECAUSE I BROUGHT BILLS UP HERE
WITH.
THAT WERE IMPORTANT TO ME AND
NOBODY ELSE BECAUSE IT ONLY
AFFECTED MY DISTRICT
AND I KNOW WHAT THAT'S LIKE.
ARE THE OTHER THING IS IS THAT I
DO KNOW.
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT BECAUSE
I'VE SEEN HOSPITAL MY DESERVE
METROPOLITAN.
AND SO PART OF THE THING THAT I
DO STRUGGLE WITH HIS
IS THAT I WILL NOT A SITUATION
WHERE THE STATE HOSPITAL HAS
SWAYED IN THE ELECTION AND IN
THE CITY OF NORWALK. OUT IT'S
PRETTY LARGE CITY.
AND
YOU KNOW.
I THINK.
THESE PEOPLE ARE DIRECTLY
AFFECTED WITH THE DECISIONS THAT
ARE BEING MADE IN THIS
CITY AND WE HAVE A LOT OF CLOSE
ELECTIONS OF TIME IN THE CITY OF
LAWYERS FOR GOOD EXAMPLE WE NEED
A NEW LIBRARY. AND WAS A
REPUBLICAN HOUSE MEMBERS AND
THE OF WHAT IT ACTUALLY PUT THIS
UP.
SOMETHING THAT ARE WAS
DIFFICULT FOR THEM BUT YET. A
LOT OF THE REPUBLICAN.
ELECTORATE THAT DID SHOW UP TO
VOTE VOTED AGAINST IT AND END UP
LOSING OUR BOND AND ORDERED IT
TO BUILD A NEW LIBRARY IT'S A
LOT OF TIMES WE HAVE A LOT OF
CLOSE ELECTIONS.
AND.
I I I STRUGGLE WITH IS IT FAIR
TO PLACE IT SPECIFICALLY ON THIS
HOSPITAL THE INMATES AT THIS
HOUR OR THE INDIVIDUALS AT THIS
HOSPITAL AS BEING THE ONES
RESPONSIBLE FOR SWING THE
ELECTION WHEN CLEARLY. IT WAS
AN ISSUE OF GETTING MORE PEOPLE
OUT IN MORE PEOPLE TO VOTE AND
IN SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE. AND
YOU KNOW IF IT IF THE CITY IS IN
SUCH DIRE NEED OF OF THESE
RESOURCES.
WHY WHAT WHY I SO WHY WASN'T IT
ARTICULATED OR OR OR PROPERLY
EXPLAINED TO THE ELECTORATE THAT
WAS VOTING TO PLEASE SHOW UP
PLEASE VOTE BECAUSE WE ARE IN A
DIRE SITUATION WE ARE IN A DIRE
POSITION?
WE DO NEED THIS TAX INCREASE TO
GET MORE PEOPLE IN SUPPORT ARE
BECAUSE I KNOW COMMUNITIES
REGARDLESS OF PARTY
REPRESENTATION THEY THEY THEY DO
TELL UP AND.
THINGS
IF THEY TRULY KNOW THAT THERE'S
A PROBLEM THAT THAT AND THAT
THERE'S JUST
A STRUGGLE THAT A PARTICULAR
COMMUNITIES HAVING SO THAT'S WHY
REALLY STRUGGLE WITH THIS BILL.
UP I WANNA I WANNA GIVE YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY
TO CAN IT CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THIS ISSUE I'M MORE THAN HAPPY
TO WORK WITH YOU ON THIS ISSUE
BECAUSE I DO HAVE A MAJOR STATE
HOSPITAL. IN MY DISTRICT.
BUT I JUST WANT REGISTER THIS
TWO CENTS A DIFFERENT
APPROPRIATIONS IS ABOUT THE
MISTER COMMITTEE BUT I DO THINK
YOU FOR WORKING ON BEHALF YOUR
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU.
AND IF I. MAY I.
.
I WOULD AGREE IN ITS HARD HAVING
THEM MAYOR RIGHT HERE BUT THE
CITY MAYBE SHOULD HAVE RUN A
BETTER CAMPAIGN.
I DON'T THINK THEY UNDERSTOOD
THAT VOTING RIGHTS HAVE BEEN
RESTORED.
WHEN THE MEASURE WAS PUT BEFORE
THE VOTERS.
AND.
I ALSO FIVE.
CAN JUST.
THE TIMING WAS OF UTMOST
IMPORTANCE.
THEY WERE REALLY TRYING TO.
THANK YOU.
TIMING NEEDED TO HAPPEN BEFORE
THE OFFICERS WERE REMOVED.
AND THAT WAS REALLY THE REASON
FOR THE SPECIAL ELECTION THAT
WASN'T THAT THAT WAS THE IDEAL
TIME FOR US TO HAV THAT
CONVERSATION IT WAS. THE ONLY
TIME.
THAT WE COULD HAVE THAT THIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
PARIS PLEASE ARTISTS WOULD JUST
LIKE TO ADD THAT TIME IN OUR TWO
THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN ELECTION
WHERE WE DID HAVE THAT THE TAX
WE HAD DOWN. I THINK EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO VOTERS AND
IN THE OFF YEAR WHERE THE ONLY
THING ON THERE WAS THIS WE HAD
ELEVEN HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN.
SO I'D SAY WE DID A PRETTY GOOD
JOB OF GETTING OUT THERE TO OUR
VOTERS AND OFF YOUR WHERE WE
ONLY HAD THIS ONE ISSUE.
BUT WE'RE DISENFRANCHISED
POPULATION WE HAVE A LARGE
HISPANIC POPULATION IT DOESN'T
VOTE WE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE
THERE THAT DON'T VOTE IT'S VERY
HARD TO GET TO THESE COMMUNITIES
AND TO GET THEM TO VOTE.
ESPECIALLY WHEN THE CITY IS
CANNOT SPEND CITY MONEY TO
ACTUALLY PROMOTE THAT'S ALL WE
CAN DO IS GIVE INFORMATION OUT
SITES ON THAT AMOUNT WE DID TRY
WE CAN WE WILL CONTINUE TO TRY
AND I THANK YOU GUYS FOR
LISTENING TO ME. THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
MISTER MARLAND.
FAMOUS CHAIR IN.
THANK MY SEAT MATE NAM FOR HIS
EFFORTS HERE AND I GENERALLY.
IN INCLINED TO GIVE DEFERENCE.
ON DISTRICT BILLS BECAUSE
THEY'RE ALL SORTS OF LOCAL
DYNAMICS THAT YOU ARE LIVING AND
BREATHING THAT WE ARE.
ON THIS DAY IS TRYING TO CATCH
UP WITH.
AYE I'M STRUGGLING WITH THE
BILL.
.
THE.
THE KEY QUESTION FOR ME BEYOND
THE LOCAL DYNAMICS IS THAT ONE
OF.
A DOMICILE AND I'M SORRY THAT I
CAME INTO THE CONVERSATION A
LITTLE LATE HERE.
THE CONCERN I HAVE IS AROUND.
.
THE POTENTIAL FOR DISCERN FOR
LOCATE.
OF THE THE PREVIOUS COMMUNITY.
OF ORIGIN.
IF THERE ARE.
UNIQUE SITUATIONS WHERE YOU
CAN'T POSITIVELY IDENTIFY.
WHERE ASSEMBLY ORIGINATED WHERE
THEY SORT OF HAD?
THE MOST.
CONNECTION.
IN A COMMUNITY. OF PRIOR THE
HARM RESIDENTS.
SO.
WHILE I DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE
A FUNDAMENTAL CONCERN AROUND.
.
DID THAT DAD VOTING RIGHTS
QUESTION ABOUT CITY OF ORIGIN
I'M JUST CONCERNED ABOUT THE
NEGATIVE BY PRODUCTS.
OF SOMEBODY WHO.
IS ON THE VOTER ROLLS RIGHT NOW.
THAT BECAUSE OF THEIR UNIQUE
SITUATION ARE NO LONGER ABLE TO
VOTE.
SO I JUST WOULD ASK THAT IF THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD THAT AND I'M
CERTAINLY MORE THAN HAPPY TO TO
WORK WITH YOU ON KIND OF.
THE THAT DIABLO UNTANGLING THAT.
QUESTION A LITTLE BIT.
I WOULD JUST ASK THAT DEBT YOU
LOOK AT THAT BECAUSE.
I AM NOT COMFORTABLE VOTING FOR
SOMETHING THAT HAS.
THE LIKELIHOOD OF
DISENFRANCHISED. PEOPLE FROM THE
VOTING ROLLS.
OKAY.
IT'S NOT.
.
SO MUCH THE THE PRIMARY ISSUE OF
WHERE THEY VOTE IT'S THAT
ULTIMATE RESULT OF SOMEBODY NOW
NOT BEING ABLE TO WAY AND.
ON.
MAJOR ISSUES CELL.
.
I JUST ASK THAT YOU.
SHOULD THE BILL MORE FOR TODAY.
LOOK AT THE POTENTIAL BYPRODUCTS
OF WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE.
IF I MAY I.
.
WE WORK QUITE INTENTIONAL WITHIN
THE BILL NOT TO TRY TO REMOVE
ANYONE'S VOTING RIGHTS.
ALL WE WERE TRYING TO DO IS HAVE
THE LAST KNOWN ADDRESS.
THE LAST KNOWN ONE.
BE WHAT WE CONSIDER AS THEIR
DOMICILE.
AND. I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
REALIZE THAT THOSE WHO ARE
RELEASED.
DON'T GET RELEASED AND TO
COALINGA OR TO FRESNO COUNTY
THEY GET RELEASED INTO THEIR
LAST KNOWN ADDRESS.
TO THEIR COUNTY OF DOMICILE.
IF WE CONSIDER AND.
THE PLACE AND PUT THEM IN THOSE
FORMER PLACES WHY DO NOT ALLOW
THEM TO VOTE.
IN THE HOMES AND COMMUNITIES
THAT THEY KNOW BETTER.
THEY'VE NEVER TOUCHED
FOOT IN CALLING UP BEFORE THEY
WERE PLACED AT THE STATE
HOSPITAL.
I.
I STRUGGLED TO TRYING TO COME UP
WITH THE SOLUTION AND REALLY
HAVE COME TO THE COMMITTEE WITH
AN OPEN MIND.
TO TRY TO WORK WITH YOU AND
FIGURE OUT HOW TO STRENGTH IN
THIS BILL IF IT IS ALLOWED TO
CONTINUE PASSED TODAY.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER HIT SO
I'D.
SORRY I WAS STUCK IN ANOTHER
COMMITTEE AND JUST GOT OUT TO
COMPETE FOR THIS ITEM.
.
I TO LIKE EVERYONE ELSE
STRUGGLES WITH THIS ITEM WITH
THIS ISSUE. UP PRIMARILY BECAUSE
I'M YOU KNOW I MEAN I I
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE GET
REDISTRICTING AND THAT WAS
REALLY A STEP SNAP IN TIME. BUT
PROBABLY PEOPLE CHANGE SEVERE.
.
SHOULD HAVE THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
WHEREVER THEY CHOOSE TO VOTE
MOST OF THE TIME. A I'M CEMENT
MOST OF US HAVE HAD KIDS WHO GOT
OFF TO COLLEGE.
AND THE SIDE THAT THEY GONNA
KEEP THEIR VOTING AT THEIR
PARENTS HOUSE.
VERSUS WHETHER CURRENTLY LIVING.
OF THE MAY CHANGE EVENTUALLY AND
SO WE'VE NEVER HAD THIS.
THIS HIGH IDEA THAT YOU KNOW
YOU CAN BE EASILY
DISENFRANCHISED ESPECIALLY
POPULATION WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
A VERY SPECIALIZED PEOPLE THAT
WE. THAT WE CAN ALMOST
GERRYMANDER OUT OF A SITUATION
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T LIKE THE
OUTCOME OF THE VOTE.
AND I THINK MANY OF US HAVE HAD
COMMUNITIES ARE ISSUES THAT HAVE
COME FORWARD THAT WE DIDN'T
REALLY. LIKE THE OUTCOME.
OF BUT WE DIDN'T THINK ABOUT.
DISENFRANCHISED IN THOSE FOLKS
IN THAT COMMUNITY FROM BEING A
PART OF THE POT THAT'S THERE WE
JUST FIGURED WE HAD TO WORK
HARDER.
TO GET OTHER FOLKS AFTER VOTE
ARE REGISTERED MORE PEOPLE OR
WHATEVER MAY BE AND I KNOW
YOU'VE GOT A UNIQUE SITUATION.
THERE BUT IT SAME.
YOUR CITY.
M. X. THESE FOLKS AREN'T
INCREASES POPULATION YOU KNOW
FOR OTHER REASONS AND NOW YOU
KNOW WITH THAT COMES.
THE GOOD THE BAD AND UGLY AND
ALL IN BETWEEN I MEAN WHEN
YOU'RE REALLY DOING SOMETHING
LIKE THAT. SO I I CAN'T REALLY
SUPPORT. IT BECAUSE IT SEEMS SO
MUCH LIKE GERRYMANDERING FOR ONE
REASON ONLY AND ARE A POPULATION
AND HOSPITAL AND WE'RE GONNA.
BASICALLY DISENFRANCHISE ARE
REQUIRE THEM TO VOTE US
SOMEWHERE ELSE OR YOU KNOW DO
NOT ALLOW THEM TO REGISTER TO
VOTE IN THAT CITY. UNLESS YOU'VE
WE'VE EVER DONE THAT BEFORE IN
TERMS OF NOT ALLOWING A PERSON
TO REGISTER TO VOTE. OF AND TO
EXERCISE THAT RIGHT TO VOTEIN
THAT PARTICULAR COMMUNITY SO. I
DON'T OF IT SETS A GOOD
PRECEDENT BAD PRECEDENT FOR THAT
TO HAPPEN.
.
I ED AND I THINK I THINK OF
MISTER HARPER FOR GIVING YOU
SOME SUGGESTIONS BECAUSE THOSE
ARE. VERY GOOD LEGAL SUGGESTIONS
ABOUT WHAT COULD HAPPEN IF YOU.
YOU THINK THIS IS YOU KNOW THIS
IS NOT THE NATURE OF THE CITY
AND THAT THE THE ANNEXING OF
THAT GROUP WAS NOT. OUR HAS NOT
BEEN BENEFICIAL YOU KNOW OF.
WHERE YOU WOULD PUT THEM IN
THOSE KIND OF THINGS IS ANOTHER
WHOLE WHOLE WHOLE LOT SITUATION
BUT? I THINK IT'S KINDA
DANGEROUS TO KIND OF WAIT INTO
THIS GERRYMANDERING OF SITUATION.
BECAUSE OF.
THE OUTCOME OF THE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL YES SIR PLEASE.
I WAS.
THERE WHEN WE.
WE DID ANNEX THAT.
STATE HOSPITAL IN AND THE
PRESENT OR NOT PRESENT BUT AT
THE STATE HOSPITAL.
AND THAT.
I REMEMBER THAT AT.
WHEN THE PEOPLE AT THE HOSPITAL
WERE BUYING THINGS.
THEY WORK THEY WORK PAYING A
LOCAL TAX.
THEY WERE THEY DIDN'T HAVE TO
PAY THE LOCAL TAX I DON'T KNOW
WHY FOR FOR THAT REASON THEY DID
BUT LATER ON IN THE YEARS THAT.
IT FOLLOWED THEN THEY HAD TO
START PAYMENT I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU REMEMBER EXACTLY WHAT DATE
IT WAS THAT THEY DIDN'T PAY
LOCAL TAXES WHEN WE FIRST.
FIRST THERE IT AND I HAVE NO WHO.
NO ANSWER WHY.
BUT I'M.
IT DOES AFFECT.
A LOT OF STUFF.
WITH ART.
THIS COUNCIL WAS GOOD.
.
YOU'RE HERE MARK THAT MONEY FOR
AT EMI STAFF.
AND THEM WITH OUR HOSPITAL
CLOSING THAT MEANS OUR AMBULANCE
WE HAVE TWO AMBULANCES AND THE
CITY OF KALINGA.
AND MOST EVERY DAY THEY'RE GONE
BECAUSE WE HAVE A STATE HOSPITAL.
AND WE HAVE A.
APPROVE THEM THERE.
AND.
THAT'S THAT'S WHO THEY UTILIZE
FIRST THAT THEY USE UP LATE TAKE
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE FROM THE
STATE PRISON AND THE STATE OFF
OF THE TAKE THE PATIENTS FROM
BOTH.
AND THEY DIDN'T AT THE NEAREST
PLACE OF HAMPERED BUT MOST OF
THE TIME THEY TAKEN TO
BAKERSFIELD.
SO WE'RE.
FOUR HOURS AWAY WITH AN
AMBULANCE EVERYDAY I MEAN IT OUR
ARE GUYS I I YOU I WAS A
VOLUNTEER AM WITH GUY. AND I I
WORK FOR THE FIRE DEPARTMENT FOR
THIRTY EIGHT YEARS OF THE
VOLUNTEER AND OF THE MONITOR
CAPTAIN.
AND I WORKED THERE FOR THIRTY
EIGHT YEARS. AND WE'VE WE'VE HAD
A LOT OF PEOPLE BUT WE JUST
DON'T HAVE THAT MANY PEOPLE
ANYMORE. AND WE'VE TRIED WE PUT
THE MONEY INTO IT. THAT IT JUST
DOESN'T COME BACK AND A LOT OF
TIMES WHERE THERE WITH NO
AMBULANCE AT ALL. AND THE
CLOSEST ONE IS TWENTY MILES AWAY
IN AND AVENEL.
AND SO IF SOMEBODY GETS HURT
HAVE A HEART ATTACK OR SOMETHING
WE DON'T EVEN HAVE A HOSPITAL
NOW.
GO THAT'S WHAT'S HURTING SO BAD.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE FIGHTING THIS.
THEY USE THE USER.
THINK
THANK YOU SAYING NO ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
DOCTORING BILL WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE.
I WOULDN'T.
I APPRECIATE THE.
PLAINTIFF AND TIME THAT THIS
COMMITTEE HAS INVESTED INTO THE
SUBJECT MATTER AND.
MY COLLEAGUES FOR HEARING US OUT.
OUR RESPONSIBILITY IS TO
REPRESENT OUR COMMUNITIES AND
NAM I HEARD AN OUTCRY.
FROM MINE ASKING FOR A SOLUTION
TO A PROBLEM.
AND IT'S THE PROBLEM THAT WE
PRESENT TO THE COMMITTEE WITHOUT
THINKING THAT WE HAVE ALL THE
ANSWERS REVIEW AND ARE WILLING
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
CHAIR IN THIS COMMITTEE AS. IF
THIS BILL IS ALLOWED TO MOVE
FORWARD.
.
BUT DO YOU JUST WANT TO RESTATE
IF I CAN'T.
NO WE'RE HERE WE TRYING TO TAKE
AWAY SOMEONE'S RIGHT TO VOTE.
WE'RE JUST TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY ARE ABLE TO VOTE IN A
PLACE WHERE THEY.
HAVE MORE TIES TO.
THAT THE COMMUNITIES THAT THEY
CAME FROM THE HOMES THAT THEY
GROW UP AND THEY UNDERSTAND
THEIR LOCAL DYNAMICS.
FOR US IN OUR LOCAL DYNAMICS.
.
CALLING DOES THE ONLY CITY I
HAVE IN MY.
DISTRICT THAT'S DECREASING IN
SIZE.
THEY HAVE HAD A TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT REDUCTION IN THEIR
POLICE FORCE THEIR HOSPITAL HAS
CLOSED DOWN.
AND.
THEY REALLY AREN'T TO US AS A
STATE
TO RECOGNIZE THE. COMMITMENTS
THAT THEY'VE MADE. TO HOUSE.
THIS STATE HOSPITAL AND A
PRISON IN THEIR BACKYARDS
AND BE AFFECTS AND UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES THAT COME FROM.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
LIFE.
THANK YOU. VERY MUCH DOCTOR
ARAMBULA FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
TODAY AND THANK YOU FOR
EVERYBODY WHO WHO. TESTIFIED ON
BOTH SIDES.
OF A TOUGH TOUGH ISSUE.
AND GOING JUST FOR SAY THAT.
OBVIOUSLY DE YEAH I'D I ADMIRE
AND RESPECT YEAH YOU'D DOCTOR
ARAMBULA AND HOW HARD YOU
ADVOCATE. FOR YOUR DISTRICT IN
THE RESPECT THAT YOU HAVE
AMONGST ALL YOUR COLLEAGUES.
WHEN YOU COME WITH WITH TOUGH
ISSUES.
AND AND I.
I TRY <c.green> DEAL WITH ME AND AND</c>
AND MY COMMITTEE STAFF SPENT A
LOT OF TIME LOOKING AT THIS
ISSUE AND TRYING TO FIGURE OUT.
YOU KNOW WHAT CHANGES COULD BE
MADE IT'S A DISTRICT ISSUE.
THAT STRIKES AT A FUNDAMENTAL
PRINCIPLE.
THAT'S A MAKES A HARD IS NOT A
DISTRICT ISSUE IN THE SENSE OF.
PERMISSION DEB TO THE BILL THE
BUILDING SOMEWHERE WHERE YOU
SHOULDN'T OR YEAH OR YOU DONT
PERMISSION OR SOMETHING LIKE
IT'S IT COMES DOWN TO VOTING
RIGHTS.
AND YOU KNOW OUR PEOPLE WHO.
DON YOU KNOW SERVED THEIR TIME
OF FOR A CRIME THEY COMMITTED
AND THEN ARE ARE RELEASED FROM
PRISON BUT ARE HOUSED IN THE
STATE. HOSPITAL A WHERE THEY GET
THEIR VOTING RIGHTS BACK.
YOU KNOW SHOULD WE FORCE THEM
TO A VOTE IN A PLACE WHERE THERE
MAY NEVER LOVE AGAIN AND AN ODDS
ARE WILL NEVER LOVE AGAIN.
.
VERSUS GIVING THEM THAT THE
OPTION OF OF REGISTERING TO VOTE
WHERE THEY LIVE.
AND THEY HAVE THAT OPTION THAT
YOU KNOW MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT.
WHEN PEOPLE GO TO THE HOSPITAL
ON THERE ARE A RELEASED IN THE
OF THE VOTING RIGHTS BACK THEY
CAN EITHER REGISTER TO VOTE
WHERE THEY. CAME FROM OR THEY
CAN REGISTER TO VOTE AT THE
HOSPITAL AND THAT'S A DECISION
THAT. THAT FOLKS MAKE THEIR.
I I THINK THAT.
SOME GOOD SUGGESTIONS WERE MADE
BY VICE CHAIR HARPER AND OTHERS.
ON ON POSSIBLE SOLUTIONS
UNFORTUNATELY A SOLUTION THAT ON
PERSONALLY AND JUST NOT
COMFORTABLE WITH. IS THIS IDEA
THAT YOU FORCE PEOPLE. ON SAID
TO VOTE FROM A PLACE THAT THEY
CAME FROM BUT MAY NEVER GO BACK
TO AGAIN.
AND ODDS ARE YOU WON'T EVER GO
BACK TO AGAIN SO I'M GONNA BE
LAYING OFF THE BILL BUT I I
FULLY. ENCOURAGE MY COLLEAGUES
TO VOTE HOWEVER THEY SEE FIT.
AND WITH THAT I'M I'M SECRETARY
WE PLEASE CALL VOTE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BERMAN NOT
VOTING BERMAN NOT VOTING HARPER.
HARPER NO CALDERON.
CALDERON I LOW. LOW AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE STEINORTH.
STEINORTH NOT VOTING AND WEBER.
WEBER NOT VOTING.
STUDENTS TO THAT BILL FAILS A
HONEST
THREE TO ONE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMERCIALISM
THANK YOU THANK.
AND WITH THAT WE YOU SOLVE.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR TO. VOTE
ON THAT IN SECTOR WE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL FOR.
SO BUT WE NEED A MOTION A SECOND.
I'VE GOT A MOTION IN TWO SECONDS.
BERMAN AYE AYE BERMAN AYE HARPER.
HARPER AYE CALDERON. CALDERON
HIGH LOW LOW AYE MULLIN. MULLIN
AYE STEINORTH STORE OWNERS AYE
WEBER.
WEBER AYE THEIR CONSENT
COUNTERSIGNED TODAY'S HEARING THANKS.
SO